[Music]
self-consciousness knows duty to be the
absolute essence it is bound only by
duty and this substance is its own pure
consciousness for which Duty cannot
receive the form of something alien
however as thus locked up within itself
moral self-consciousness is not yet
posited and considered as consciousness
the object is immediate knowledge and
being thus permeated purely by the self
is not an object but because self
consciousness is essentially a mediation
and negativity its notion implies
relation to an other mnestheus Ness this
other 'no studi constitutes the sole aim
and object of consciousness is on the
one hand of reality completely without
significance for consciousness but
because this consciousness is so
completely locked up within itself it
behaves with perfect freedom and
indifference towards us other nests and
therefore the existence of this other
nests on the other hand is left
completely free by self consciousness an
existence that similarly is related only
to itself the freer self consciousness
becomes the freer also is the negative
object of its consciousness the object
has thus become a complete world within
itself with an individuality of its own
a self-subsistent whole of laws peculiar
to itself as well as an independent
operation of those laws and a free
realization of them in general a nature
whose laws like its actions belong to
itself as a being which is indifferent
to moral self-consciousness just as the
latter is indifferent to it
with paragraph 599 we are now beginning
this new section this final portion of
the spirit part of the work morality
we're beginning this in earnest and
Hegel titles this sub subsection the
moral view of the world moral here is
translating more Alicia we've already
talked about the distinction between the
moral and the ethical the more Alicia
and the silica on the one hand so I'm
not going to really go into that here
but there's another term that I think is
worth pointing out as we begin this
section view of the world is translating
a term that in its german has made its
way into english at least in literate
circles belt on Shaolin and sometimes
this is translated very literally as
world intuition or world view on Zhang
has this this you know sort of like
taking things in and grasping them all
together and adult you know we might
think of this as a systematic approach
to everything that matters veldt
world here is not just referring to say
the globe right it means the entire
world that we inhabit our environment
our our universe if you will so a moral
Zelda and showing a moral view of the
world is indeed taking morality as not
just what the most important would be in
in German you know
victus right but what is essential J'son
Tahlequah but what is really at the core
of things and so this is part of the
progress of self consciousness
attempting to figure out who it is and
what it is and how it fits in with the
rest of
what it encounters and understands or
another way of putting that what it is
conscious of what it is consciousness of
so this is a very important transition
point another thing that I would like to
point out and I'll keep talking about
this throughout this commentary is that
it's very natural I think for the
typical reader knowing that that Hegel
is within this grand tradition of German
idealism
which we we typically take as beginning
with the manual content we know that
Kant stressed morality above everything
else that that you know there's a very
you might say formal that is content
less understanding of morality that that
conte is going to articulate Hegel is
not just talking about conch in morality
here he's talking about something more
broad something found throughout the
culture something that would take you
know the the consciousness the
understanding of duty as being central
and he is also going to be as we're
going to see already in this paragraph
beginning to develop but even more in
the later paragraphs talking about a
sort of conflict or productive
contradiction or word that Miller will
often use antithesis between Duty or
freedom or morality or self
consciousness in that sense and nature
nature with a capital end you might say
don't automatically assimilate this to
the anthropological distinction between
nature and culture because the the
natural includes a lot more that falls
in
to the cultural sphere but this is going
to be a theme that will come up over and
over again it is really central to the
entire problematic that's being worked
out and one more thing to say before we
actually go into the text
what is Hagel doing in this section what
is he doing in this this last part of
spirit what is he doing in this
subsection he is exploring what the
moral point of view on human being the
world society everything that matters
what it shows itself to be when we you
might say give it free range when we
observe to see how it works through its
own problematic not just what it's
attempting to resolve not just how it's
imposing itself on something else in
this case its other other nets right but
how it's going to self-consciously
attain to some realization of its own
inconsistencies or its own inadequacies
its own gaps and then how is it going to
try to move past that that's really
what's at the core of this now as usual
we have a very optimistic beginning
point seems like we've made our way to
something radically new in the history
of ideas if you remember at the end of
this section really we moved at the very
end of the the absolute freedom and
terror into this now spirit that is
certain of itself morality we had this
connection between willing and knowing
you know villain and misson and we're
gonna see this played out here so he
says self consciousness is at the
beginning of the paragraph knows duty
Duty is pleased right to be the absolute
essence now this doesn't just mean I'm
flicked a single duty
this means the entire range of duties
but it also means the general conception
of duty obligation what it is that we
are motivated to do and this is central
to what Hegel is calling morality not
just Hegel of course but pretty much so
many other people in his own time
so he says self consciousness knows duty
to be the absolute essence to be what is
essential that which is most important
that which could in fact yield it the
answers to the questions about itself
that it has been looking for so he says
it's bound only by Duty not now that's
worth dwelling up it's bound only by
Duty was that the case for self
consciousness in so many other cases
before consider all of the we might say
ethical or moral not in Hegel sense but
just in a broad sense all of the
normative steps that self-consciousness
or spirits through human beings had to
go through all the way up until this
stage of the dialectic can we genuinely
say of each of them that there is
something that self-consciousness found
itself bound by yes bound both in two
senses bound in the one sense of having
to recognize as essential as important
as motivating it we saw that in earlier
places Hegel called this the sokka's
Elst right the ayah translated this
myself as project it was often
translated in many other ways by Miller
as well and this could be pleasure which
turns out to reveal to us necessity it
could be a law of the heart it could be
trying to make sense of things through
giving laws to itself it could be
identifying itself with the family
or with the city the divine law or the
human law it could be and we could go on
and on and on all of those things all of
those normative bindings now have given
way to that of flicked Duty we can also
say that a something is binding in
another way binding in the sense and
here I'm going to do a little play on
words which I usually don't indulge but
in the English language is so facile in
this amount it's a blind it's it's a
binding that is also a blinding when you
have blinders on like when we put them
on to an animal who we want to only pay
attention to what's in front of it
people often speak of themselves as
having blinders
you know they stare at a screen and
they're unaware of what's going on
around them that is a constraint that is
a constraint on what can be understood
what can be thought what can be made
sense of so any sort of normative Center
any any great project of that sort in
this case Duty can have that sort of
force as well it opens up for us new
things that we can think but it also
conceals so going on it's bound only by
duty and he says this substance is its
own pure consciousness for which Duty
cannot receive the form of something
alien something that is other than
itself something it cannot understand
something it cannot assimilate something
that it has to actually get to know it
thinks I know what my duties are I am
conscious of them and you know if
somebody says well why is this a duty or
you know what if I don't recognize this
as a duty at a certain sense at a
certain point rather a duty is something
that you recognize there's what we could
call a moral bedrock and if you have to
explain that something is a duty
to another person that's something wrong
on their part there's something missing
there at least at this stage right
Haeckel goes on and he says this
self-consciousness is locked up within
itself so he calls this moral
self-consciousness and he says it's not
yet positive and considered as
consciousness so it is
self-consciousness in that it has a
relation to self it recognizes both
through knowing and through willing that
it ought to behave in certain ways and
it ought to fulfill certain conditions
that it has duties before it but it
doesn't grasp itself as consciousness
it's missing out on something important
well what is this
so here Hegel is going to lead us
through several lines into you know what
could be a good summary of Hegel's views
on consciousness he says the object is
immediate knowledge object is gagging
stop right Gagan stand is something that
you can have before yourself and part of
being conscious is being conscious of an
object it doesn't have to be an object
like a physical object like this as a
matter of fact each of these words is an
object in that sense a gag and not
something that stands before us the
senses the meanings of the paragraphs
and the the sentences those can be Gagan
stand lika as well those present
themselves to us in an objective way not
objective as opposed to subjective but
objective as they are there for us so
self-consciousness has to have an object
consciousness always does have an object
actually it hasn't usually multiple
objects right so he goes on and he says
the object is immediate knowledge and
being thus permeated purely by the self
is not an object it's not yet an object
it is not yet made into an object so
here he brings up something
very interesting he says because
self-consciousness is essentially two
things a mediation and negativity all
right because self-consciousness is
essentially a mediation that is it is
going to be connected with and having
its meaning correlative lis in terms of
what it is connected with in the
mediation and it's also not only
mediating the other things to itself its
mediating itself so there's that one
side there and it's also as he says a
negativity
notice what he doesn't say it's not a
negation
it's a negativity consciousness we've
been over this many times is a kind of
lack that's why consciousness can be
conscious on something it makes room it
allows that that thing to fall into it
if there wasn't any negative space
within consciousness for that to happen
then that would not be a possibility for
it but that is of the essence of
consciousness so because of this
mediation and negativity Hegel says it's
notion implies relation to and other
nasai now notice that he doesn't say
just an other and under right or an
alien thing I you know it's friendís he
says an other Ness something that is
some being that is other consciousness
cannot remain solely locked up within
itself it has to be related by virtue of
being conscious to something that is
different than itself something that is
more or less something that is other so
he goes on and he says here we go and
other Ness and thus is consciousness
this other nests be
cuz Duty is the sole aim and object of
consciousness how is how is
consciousness going to understand the
southern he says it is on the one hand a
reality completely without significance
for consciousness a reality without
significance for consciousness at this
point it's there it's operative it's
part of the belt on Xiao long the belt
that that is being grasped but it is not
yet grasped explicitly he goes on again
in that and he says because this
consciousness is so completely locked up
within itself what consciousness the
moral consciousness it behaves with
perfect freedom and indifference towards
this other Ness now that's a little bit
different saying that it behaves with
complete freedom and indifference is not
the same thing as saying that other news
just isn't there at all I can be
completely indifferent to the objects in
front of me for example as I'm shooting
this video I prop my book up on this
stool and quite frankly unless it gets
in my way or unless I want to use it as
an example or if the book doesn't lay
flat on it the way I need it to i'm
pretty indifferent to it i'm not really
paying attention to it i'm paying
attention to the book that I'm picking
up putting down and the you know it
could be a chair it could be a stool
could be a lectern I don't care what it
is
now that's indifference I am noticing it
in front of me but I just don't care and
I behave towards the stool at least more
or less with complete freedom I walk
over here and now I walk over here now
of course if I walked towards you which
I wouldn't do because I'd want to you
know be dominating the entire camera I
would bump into the stool hey but that's
you know that that's a constraint now
this this other knows moral
self-consciousness insofar as it's aware
of its duty does it have to take the
other into account
because it can do its duty it can
recognize its duty without having to
care what that thing is this is what we
can call a formal morality I'll give you
an example here don't why don't say
anything that is not true well what
about this case and what about this case
is it ok if I lie to my kids all that
involves some sort of other nough some
sort of determinacy that adds something
to the situation and the person who's
just focused on duty over here can say
no it doesn't there's no exceptions just
don't lie that a lot not lying is a duty
telling the truth is a duty now this is
not going to be tenable for long well
let's go on and see what he says so I
says it behaves with perfect freedom and
indifference therefore the existence of
this other nests left completely free by
self consciousness now here it gets
quite interesting not only is there
freedom on the side of the moral
consciousness
there's also freedom on the side of this
other than this there's like enough
freedom to go around you can say that's
the nice thing about freedom is when you
actually do have freedom freedom kind of
leads to more freedom in some cases so
he says the existence of this other Ness
is left completely free by self
consciousness and existence that
similarly is related only to itself now
we're starting to get two sides closed
off from each other and this is going to
lead us to something important now
notice the dynamic that he talks about
here the freer self-consciousness
becomes the freer also is the negative
object of its consciousness which is
this other this so as freedom is
increasing on one side freedom is also
increasing on the other side what does
that mean for us it could mean multiple
things we might you know early on here
think of you know Kant's kingdom of ends
and the promotion of freedom and that's
but Hegel is not going there yet and
studying is going to talk about
something else let's take a look this is
the last part of this paragraph so he
says the object the Gaghan stop what was
the object first our duties our
self-consciousness not this thing over
here but now the other the other Ness is
becoming a different kind of object the
object has become a complete world
within itself with an individuality of
its own now isn't that an interesting
way to talk think about that for a
minute
the object has become a world within
itself it's become closed off in its own
sphere with an individuality of its own
do we normally talk about the world in
the sense of this you know surrounding
environment as having an individuality
it's that really the sort of thing where
we would talk about it having
individuality or something that's not
individual like being universal or being
generic okay the world is the world in a
certain sense those categories of
individuality or universality don't
really apply that well to it the way
they do to things like us but if we're
considering the human being and human
beings consciousness as sort of a cosmos
and a cosmos that can somehow connect up
with the larger cosmos then maybe it can
have individuality keep that in your
back pocket whenever individuality comes
up individuality always has a sort of to
stabilizing force within the Galleon
dialectics so just keep that in mind now
he goes on and he says it's become a
complete world within itself a
self-subsistent whole of laws peculiar
to itself laws laws can't just be about
idiosyncratic individuals now can they
they have to
then there's scope otherwise they're
just you know with rules something like
that in order for them to be laws to be
part of a world there has to be
something more going on here again
Hegel's not completely showing his hand
so we have a in we have laws peculiar to
itself and then he goes further as well
as an independent operation of those
laws and a free realization of them a
free realization of those laws how can
you actually have freedom and law going
together if it's a law doesn't it simply
compel doesn't it coerce doesn't it
impose a sort of necessity upon us well
remember when we looked at laws in the
past you might think all the way back to
the reason section when we looked at
observing reason and then we talked
about psychological laws and then we
looked at that whole fizzy item II for
knowledge II section laws do in fact
require a certain interpretation even
moral laws do again
Hegel's not really thematize Ingush yet
here but it is coming up so just keep
that in the back of your mind as we move
through the rest of these paragraphs he
finishes by saying that because it's
these whole laws and an independent
operation of these laws and a free
realization it is a nature whose laws
like its actions belong to itself as a
being which is indifferent to moral
self-consciousness now we're talking
about what this other nests
a nature capital n actually all capital
letters here nature a nature that is
going to be different from something
that is related to but not the same
thing as morality or the moral
self-consciousness or the moral view of
the world the moral view of the world
you could say consists in part in
self-consciousness grasping its own
relation to this nature
this other news so it's gonna have to go
outside of its bubble its shell it's
self-contained seer and find yet another
self-contained sphere than it has to
explore in order to make sense of this
so he talks about this as a nature whose
laws like its actions belong to itself
as a being which is indifferent to moral
self-consciousness just as the latter is
indifferent to them so now we have two
big players on the scene
Hegel has now established some of the
grand outlines of what we are going to
be now discussing he hasn't as I said
completely shown his hand but he's at
least laid out for us the problematic
morality of nature
you